in this video I want to give a brief
overview of the PIP to IP 3d AG
signaling cascade so what's going on
with that cascade or that pathway we
have a hormone bind at g-protein coupled
receptor just like we've been talking
about and that same idea conformational
change activates this g-protein causing
the alpha subunit to be have its gdp
replaced the gtp and it's activated in
this case though with this cascade the
g-protein is not a G stimulatory it's a
GQ and I'm not exactly sure what that
stands for but just be aware of that
difference there so what is this G alpha
subunit do or what's the effector enzyme
in this case the effector enzyme is no
longer a generalized cyclase in this
case it's a PLC or phospholipase see
I've drawn a little sort of legend here
for all these different abbreviations so
what plc does or phospholipase see what
it does is it Cleaves pip 2 which is
phosphor phosphatidyl inositol for 5
bisphosphate which is this thing here
this entire structure here it Cleaves it
into da G which I've drawn here and this
little yellow circle which is IP 3 so da
Jie is diacylglycerol and IP 3 is in
this inositol 1 4 5 triphosphate so both
of these things here let me note that
here actually this and this are both
second messengers so now what these two
things do is IP 3 goes over to the
endoplasmic reticulum and it binds a
calcium ion channel and what it does is
it allows the calcium from inside of the
endoplasmic reticulum specifically the
the lumen of the endoplasmic reticulum
and allows these little calcium ions
here it allows them to flow out into the
cytosol
and some of them if they get the chance
even what they'll do is they'll actually
bind this thing that we hear which I'll
get to in just a second so
diacylglycerol goes over to pkc which is
protein kinase C so protein kinase C is
what it was it's a - protein kinase
right just like we've talked about
protein kinase a before it adds
phosphates to target proteins so these
calcium ions help activate help help D
AG activate protein kinase C so the
calcium ion and the D AG both work
together to activate protein kinase C
and once protein kinase C is activated
what it does as it triggers the
phosphorylation of that target protein
or a particular target protein and that
triggers a cellular response now this is
of course the general scheme so it's
different for a variety of cases this
actual signaling cascade or pathways in
a bunch of different cells so depending
on the cell that's actually being bound
and the hormone of course being about
binding the receptor there could be a
variety of different things happening in
this okay so I hope that brief overview
was helpful I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email at MU for university at
gmail.com thank you for watching